i'm ready to eat
i'm ready to cook look at that y'all
look so good
i'm ready to learn wow that's so good
hi my name is vanessa and i love food
the kitchen has always been my true
place of comfort i currently work at one
of the hottest restaurants in downtown
l.a as a pastry chef but getting there
was not easy while most chefs had the
ability to work under other high-ranking
chefs and intern for them i pretty much
only had my grandmother my mama in our
kitchen now that i'm ready to tackle the
world of entrepreneurship and start my
own business i wanted to meet with the
most popular chefs in my community to
see how they maintain their sense of
culture and their dishes especially when
they have an audience that doesn't
always look like them so we're taking a
trip around america to see what these
chefs had to endure on their path to
success have some tunnel vision don't
try to do 9 million things at once learn
more about their favorite culturally
inspired dish and finally get a chance
to taste my
roots should we stop making that noise
no so come join us this is tasting our
roots
[Music]